this is my band guys this is my band
this is my how's it going kiddo it's jam
sesh time yeah
come on when jam sesh time arrives we
have to put aside childish things like
homework and med school I have to close
the shop I'm sorry Frank I held off on
raising the rent as long as I could
made it's time my girl starts UCLA in
the fall you can't make your heart feel
like what just a bunch at work I want it
that way they want what what way I'm
sorry are you bringing up the Backstreet
Boys it's actually a pretty good song
[Music]
you don't always get to do what we love
though we need to love what we do I
never realized that was your secret yeah
[Music]
since I was like 12 we're not a band I
like it
I don't want to be in a band and even if
I did I'm not gonna be in one with my
dad usually what is this you and DMX on
Spotify this is my band you guys this is
my band this is my man okay so what do I
do now I mean we could write another
song this is so good
you wrote this yeah my dad Sam talks to
me now like she's the adult it's just
her way of making it easier for you a
mini
maybe even take a year off and we'll see
what happens are you suggesting that I
don't go to college so that I can stay
and being a band you have the same thing
that your mother had and if she were
here right now I've been here my whole
life I don't want something it's time to
get away
let's just do our thing what thing we've
never done this before this is what we
always do
just in front of some people hey that's
what bands tutoring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you